okay let's move to the coven nineteen
laboratory testing forum and we are very
pleased to have dr. fessor come being
one as our forum chair as well as three
distinguished the forum speakers dr.
Frank young dr. Jason Chen and dr. Asian
gel and my name is Ruben rule I am the
board secretary of NACA and clinical
chemistry fellow of UC San Francisco the
professor can be one as our forum chair
today is going to give us a an overview
of the laboratory testing contents of
the newly published Chinese guidelines
treatment guidelines for covering
nineteen and dr. Wong is the director of
Clinical Laboratory of PLA General
Hospital and the chairman of Chinese
society of Laboratory Medicine and he
has contributed a lot into the
laboratory medicine field as it
distinguished the leader of Chinese
medical community especially in
laboratory medicine so we are very
honored to have professor from being one
today to give us the the newest
information and message of the new
guidelines in terms of the laboratory
testing professor Wong please okay it's
my Chinese comment rezulin a postulate
adjust the published the seventh edition
Fleur Cara 9/4 a closest and
achievements for lower a colonel virus
pneumonia yeah
for this night I don't want to read word
by word I just want to give a general
its price its brushing you know for a
routine test I think Anna man different
SiC differences to different event the
archer from the pictorial you know in
faction but as I need to not easy to
different ad from the flu virus because
so that it sees are so complex you know
fall alas the slides
yeah but if ya know okay for loop like
acid has I think the you know weird
where the specimen collected from is
very important you know less specimen to
collect affirm lower respiratory tract
you know such as air we know leverage of
fluid and sputum to get the post he read
now I think it's higher you know for
virus elliptic as a test high post he'll
read an order is a weenie when a
laboratory fluid is the higher than the
sputum and the hires in less origin
effort for you forgive us
you know throbs get him from knows and
it's a higher than our reference you
know for NGO a swab swab versus get into
mouse a mouse
yeah but L will love it afloat and a
sputum specimens a klappa from you know
from lower respiratory tract if code
because there are universal in vessel
now so who do you know cut from a card
from here in the didn't get the tuber
into today now or two together
crude and simple out so I think most
people I don't want to do it for lower
Cloris alimony Oh our confirms you know
in Carolina to do is astray and their
first race the positive results in the
detection of the lower lower crime
acronym iris acid a second is the
sequence of the virus a higher know
Colonel virus I think they said about
the to as I don't want to say something
justice or a specific IGM and igg
anybody an attached a postive in the
serum I just don't want to give a little
its brand it's fresh it's bland it's
bland you know first Lisa ITM and ITT
you know anybody's test the post a
result must must be later than the
nucleic acid a test I was I think it's a
very important so if we want you get
here with a closest area full of virus
maybe it's a I have some some problem
Saturday is IBM and ITT anybody's test
them you know my presenter force post
you are for selective results yeah
Authority if IDM and a GT anybody it has
to just the one hand I think it's
difficult to make a confirm a diagnosis
but continues monitor monitoring you
know anybody resolves or maybe more
careful to you here for careful to a
communicative per ticket or something
yeah
because of anybody where do you you you
get a new server time to test you know
that the results are maybe in a higher
and higher
I may say I think a so where
significance okay I just the one who
says this thank you so much professor
Wong and I think it's very clear that
besides the inflammatory analytes that
the confirmatory tests on nucleic acid
and especially the antibody serological
tests that you mentioned and the you
emphasized it's very helpful I think
this information can help a lot for the
people are who for the labs who are
going to start having nineteen testing
in the United States okay now let's move
to the panel discussion session we are
very pleased to have invited
distinguished speakers dr. Frank Young
from adhikam dr. Jason Chen from King
ding mad doctor you shouldn't jam from
DeeAnn they all have pretty much
experience in fighting the carbon 19 in
the front line in terms of doing the
clinical laboratory testing so we would
like to have our three discs R integral
speakers to talk about just to discuss
you know around these questions and you
provide us their opinions so let's move
to the first question the question is
how are samples collected and processed
to be tested in reference laboratories
we would like to ask dr. Frank yang from
Eric count you gave us his input on
question number one our young piece
thank you dr. law and thank you
professor Wong first I would like to
thank naka for organizing that forum I'm
dr. yang of ethical medical laboratories
I'm honored to be invited to this forum
along with my fellow speakers dr. Chen
of a team man and adopted young of the
add like Lavrov and the question in the
United States he mad ER and I recon our
top three independently funny
laboratories in China about two months
ago and any research first
this year I'd come along with the
biggest competitors of Kim Matt and
Diane had formed a national front line
coalition against the call it 19th we
are here not as competitors but as
comrades answering this question I have
to say our experience only apply to
independent clinical laboratories that
may be different from CDC laboratory and
the practical hospitals that's probably
why we have this session from mass
December to late January samples were
handled almost exclusively by CDC during
this time samples of fact about hospital
staff and the process by CDC
laboratories or public hospitals by
January 2007 independent clinical
laboratories were recording in samples
start to be distributed to BGI prodigy
in Timnath GE yeah and egg hunt this was
the first time independent clinical
laboratory were called in to help large
optical health crises the reactants and
the protective supplies were provided by
CDC this has work conducted strictly
following the manufacturer's
instructions has the results were
reported to CDC in batches without
issuing laboratories on past reports
that is a very unique experience for us
trained pathologist also in China there
is a mandatory viral inactivation step
before testing has start all samples
have to go through the process at the 55
56 degrees
ceases for 30 minutes using either a
water press or F block lists that may or
may not affect
test results the participation of
non-public adapter is quickly
bumped up the capacity of a virus
testing to tens of sounds / - I had
concurrently wrong about 20,000 samples
per day the fast expansion of the test
capacity and extension of a test based
from patients to close contacts were
critical to stop Corbett a 19 spring
that's my answer hey thank you very much
dr. young I think that's very good
comprehensive and very concise answer I
think it's really valuable especially as
you know the u.s. labs are just stepping
to the testing of this
I mean pandemic virus I think this is a
very useful experience share okay so the
second question is about the best
practices in collecting respiratory
specimens and the effective protection
for the sampling stuff I would like to
pass this question to dr. Jason Chen
from Kingman Diagnostics dr. Jessop
recent Chen is a very experienced
biologist and he has a lot of experience
I'm having the samples also target dr.
Chen please thank you for the
introduction
we have collect samples from swaps with
swaps usually throat swaps or nasal
swabs and also he puts Putin and puff on
carry on a very fluid
puff usually collected by a physician
and we you to collect swab samples so
for the swab samples we use there's some
most standard procedure which can be
seen from the video available and what
we emphasize to collect it the
importance of the collects specimen is
to keep the Swap above the tissue for
about 10 seconds and a 10 around as
couple of times before you take out so
that you can get more sales because
viruses inside cells that's important
and for the swab test itself we use
synthetic fiber
swaps with little brush and tip and for
the personal protection we use gloves
masks which is 995 long sleeve what
resistant corn and the go-go's also face
shield thank you dr. Chen these are very
useful tips and techniques and yeah this
are very I mean I can benefit the
colleagues in the United States who want
to start the hammering the samples for
the testing of covering 19 samples now
let's move to our question number three
what are the effective protection for
laboratory professionals when handling
blood urine stool and respiratory
specimens so this is actually a very
actually a key question you know or the
u.s. colleagues who are just in begin to
do the testing of all types of specimens
I think dr. Frank young from Attica also
has a lot of experience and let's get
his input on this question dr. young
please elaborate to a laboratory or
people laboratory is adequate to handle
over the 19 according to authorities as
well as experts but we reach the person
of protection to level 3 this included a
95 face mask
D'Argo's our face shields double gloves
had disposable protective clothes and
the shoe covers that has the word
contact in certified the PCR labs that
is designed to minimize nucleic acid
contamination the concern of a sample
related aerosol can be effectively
protected by making sure the ventilation
system is the functional following is
strictly the laboratory pros
and the taking level three personal
protection measures this is a true to
all respiratory samples as well as a
broad urine and a stool since the
February 1st ed has processed closer to
a half a million Coby the 19 nucleic
acid test many employees have
participated in sample collection sample
transportation and the sample process so
far none of our employees has been
infected
that's my answer thank you dr. Jung I
think that's very effective to that
protect all your techniques technicians
and employees just from none of them
infection that's that's a pretty much a
big achievement yeah we would like to
direct the same question number three to
dr. Jeong and dr. each engine has
experience managing the reference
laboratory and managing the
professionals so dr. John could you give
us some input on question number three
okay thank you
hello I'm dr. Jim from the antagonizes
which is largely stream dependent a
clinical lab in China just like LabCorp
requesting America I'm not working on
the virus detection of the clinical
trial as most of the simple they are
handling now our first few samples I
think maybe we have something useful to
share with you firstly you have to
remind you that this virus is a very
very terrible railers it's not just like
a big flow so you should pay attention
to every detail during your work as you
think that your awareness of protection
is always the best protection of
yourself and as you know that before you
enter the lab you should we're the
protection closing and the boats to
protect your body and to to protect your
face a face mask with positive air
pressure is the best choice but if you
do not have such kind of mask I advise
you through the we're n95
breathing mask to protect your
respiratory and protection go go go
of this screen
protect your eyes and you have to wear
double gloves to protect your hands all
of those things that you can learn from
guidelines and here I want to share
something that you some details that you
can you may not learn from guidelines
theory or work the air you breathe out
and do the switch of your face make will
make your glasses as mask fogging up
it's not convenient and will be very
dangerous if you could not see clearly
so I advise you to prepare some anti fog
scenes like and D for Jill to protect
your glasses or mask from fogging up and
during your operation my appearance is
that is that your gloves are very easy
to fall off from your wrist so we
already use some plastic tips to stick
the blows to the sleeves of the closing
of the protection clothing to prevent
our clothes from falling for up all the
simples here we are we operating our
were inactivated by 56 degrees
centigrade for 30 minutes before
operation that will mix the virus in
activity so it's much received in
merciful safe and all the simples should
be prepared in the biological safety
convenient the biological safety
cabinets is the most important equipment
here well we all used a b2 level
feminine to here I suggest you to check
the wind the direction of the community
before and during using it here we use a
little piece of paper stick to the plan
at each of the glass to observe the wind
direction so maybe it's a good message
for you tune among all those other
simple types
spume simple is most dangerous because
it has the highest high least positive
reach the high least a virus load and
requires much more convenient completed
processing steps we here we try the
different kinds of pretreatment since
the although the sodding magics and is
is much more it is a little better than
protein yursky
the virus load tested by appreciative in
sodium hydrogen of Frattini earth key is
much more simple and here we choose to
use protein yursky
to appreciate its beauty ohms simcoe's
here we use 50 55 55 centigrade degrees
centigrade for 30 minutes who is 13
linear ski to link Levi is a sputum
samples so that's the things that I can
share I you can share about his question
thank you thank you so much dr. John I
think your input is very valuable and
useful these tips and techniques for the
colleagues working in the United States
I think they definitely need to know
these and pay attention to the different
sample types just one quick follow-up
question I heard like in the medical
community in the United States some
people thought that serum samples could
be safe because there seems like there's
some preliminary studies showing a very
kind of like undetectable viral load in
Syria more plasma samples could you
comment on that is that really safe I
don't think I think I don't think that
about it so because I think that you are
a kind of
simple server dangerous also maybe you
cannot detect out is a virus RNA because
of like simple types are those kind of
things but it doesn't mean that the
virus is not exist so I advise you to
treat every kind of simple and it seemed
degree of careful
I see that yeah thank you for again for
the great answer and now let's move to
question number four as we know next
generation sequencing technology can
give you provide you a more
comprehensive information about the gene
sequence of the virus so could you
comment on the role of the
next-generation sequencing and how
applicable this technology is for the
diagnosis of copy 19 okay
next-generation sequencing is a very
important research tool for the
molecular diagnosis I think it's very
useful in the murderous investigation
works like a virus population analyze
tracing and the mutation detections as
you know that a new the virus always
mutti occurs mutation BIA during the
spread of the virus the clinical and the
infection characters may be changed
because of important mutations and at
this time maybe we needed to use NGS to
investigate the variation of the virus
but I don't think ingest can play an
important role in daily detection of
virus because at all you know that the
operation steps are too complicated and
takes too long time and it has a high
cost just like a reminder you at the
beginning a virus is a very very
dangerous virus it is very fast I
believe that just means mainly maybe
several days on at at most you may be
several weeks I really will have to face
a very large number of Chester everyday
clinicians and CDC's you need to know
that just real outs in hours and you
know that in general and yes cannot you
ask whether the patient is infected or
not just in such a short time so and
also the cost of NGOs are much more
expensive even so it's not suitable for
daily detection of them in fact here the
infection or not so it's much more like
that immaterial if we have
good value in research and investigation
but not in theory use our experience is
the infection diagnosis of most patients
here rely on real-time PCR and as we see
is much easier to operate and the result
can be given up to in several hours and
much more cheap so the sensitivity and
specificity are very high chip so most
of the patients were diagnosed Reacher
hill by the RTP thermistor dance is much
more suitable for daily detection of
large numbers ox and host that's how
thank you
I see dr. John so it just very quickly
also you don't I think it means you
didn't see a higher clinical specificity
or clinical sensitivity using
next-generation sequencing compared to
PCR
sensitivity and the specificity is good
for ingest but to the time cons the time
is too long and in the coast is not
proper suitable for daily detection and
I think that artists are it's much
suitable for detection for large numbers
of samples
I see so next-gen sequencing is not like
a superior in terms of the clinical
utility compared yeah yeah it's much
more like research - or like
investigation - but not really used
Diagnostics true okay I see that thank
you so much for answering this question
I think it's very valuable
you got thank you thank you okay so for
this next gen sequencing question I
would like also get the opinion from dr.
Jason Chen from Piemonte
Diagnostics dr. Cheng could you comment
on the usefulness of next-gen sequencing
in the diagnosis
okay the next generation sequencing is a
powerful method to sequencing all the
being a nucleic acid inside sample
although it's take a little bit longer
time and cost much more than real time
PCR and more importantly it has less
sensitivity then fish' so in practice I
think when we know the sequence of the
genome and now we have the specific
target which is new coronavirus we I
don't think we need to use NGS routinely
for detection real-time PCR is quicker
and more specific and so it's thick and
it cost too much less so it's a faster
way to to to to choose thank you dr.
Chen
I think this input is very useful it's
practical and it's also consistent with
the answer from dr. John the fifth
question let's move into this question
this is actually recently raised pretty
much attention in the medical community
in the United States that's about the
other tests so the nucleic acid Pesta we
all know it's very important it's the
kind of like the size I mean the
decisive the diagnosis method but also
antibody tests people now realize the
IgG IgM test can be complimentary well
that's you might dr. Frank young could
you give us just your input on question
number five Thank You Koby the 19 is
relatively new it's epidemiologist study
is far from over with some limited
studies nucleic acid test had a positive
rate of 60 to 70 percent in
cute face and the gradually decreased to
48 to 50 percent ill in the course the
low detection rate or the so called high
false negative rate of a nucleus as the
test is not due to the test itself but
most likely due to sampling this is a
pattern you do to our inability to
sample entire respiratory tract viral
load in Franks and upper respiratory
tract is relatively low compared to
lungs viral load may be too low to be
detected in the sampling area at a
certain diseases stages this may explain
why some patients ativan for the coab at
the nineteen you mo NIA while swaps were
tested next year
on another hand anybody test that has
been recently available to us has a
loaded hacking rate in acute efface
about a 38 to 40 percent
especially igg but increased to 70
percent at a to 90s and the 100% after
12 days according to one study
therefore nucleic acid test and
serological and abided as our
complementary to each other currents and
antibody IV DS are mostly PSHE using
Connery gold due to Raj for a proof
under the special circumstances many
IEDs have not been properly vetted that
they need to be carefully validated in
lab to find out it's a true sensitivity
and the specificity our specific study
conducting hide account for say
fda-approved IV d showed 100% disability
in about 2000 the cooperating employees
who participate ad can organize return
to work screening our parallel study of
a full antibody IV DS two of them were
say fda-approved should across-the-board
a high surface of a city as well but
they have very intensities against
nucleic acid possible a positive samples
that indicating some IV DS may be more
sensitive than others
the specificity and sensitivity reported
in recent literature were 90 to 99
percent for specificity and 89 to 95
percent for sensitivity respectively
that's it thank you dr. yeah just a very
quick follow-up question do you think
because people also started talking
about antigen tests so do you think that
it's possible to detect the antigen and
in the serum samples
that is very possible because antigen
test has been T bad food recently but
unfortunately and none of them have been
passed at the say of tear proof from the
the preliminary results the antigen
tests using salsa related antigen or
newly manufactured ending in the lab
showed very high concordance with the
nucleic acid it has but those results
has not been published I say that thank
you very much dr. Jung okay so for this
question about utility of nucleic acid
test and antibody tests I would like
also ask doctor dr. chan dr. Jason Chan
from Kingman Diagnostics as we know like
you mad is one together with at account
and at the end of one of the largest
clinical laboratories in China so you
must have a large throughput and
capacity in the testing of the carbon 19
samples so could you comment on how you
integrate you could gas a test and
anybody tests and how you just position
these different tests dr. Japanese okay
as a king bed we have started the test
since Chinese New Year January 25th so
far we have been dying 1.6 million tests
already and 20,000 tests per day we
initially used nucleic acid test as
everybody which is required by the CDC
in China so this actually ninety more
than 90 percent sample has been
testified this way and recently we have
used immunological sa as well to test
the
fishing and anybody to the new
coronavirus both IGM and igg we have
compared three different kids in chinese
market one of them to detect IGM and igg
specific antibodies by chemiluminescence
and another to method is the tap the
total in monopoly against the corner
runs energy they use different method
one is luminescence
the other one is by colloidal code so
the specificity of this method is very
good it's 97 to 100 percent the same
sensitivity is around 80 to 90 percent
so we have been using this but we don't
have lots of experience on it on them
because it's just started about one week
ago when we do the validation in Wuhan
the awesomes performed pretty good as
they indicated or they claimed in the
instruction
I think this immunology test is a good
complement to the nucleic acid testing
because the anybody has the is more use
the serum which is most standardized
sample compared to those swaps oh thank
you
hm I have a follow-up question you
mentioned that you have used the camera
message si which is can which can be
like either quantitative or qualitative
and you also mentioned the coloring
don't gold tests which is like more like
the lateral flow point-of-care testing
or just yes or no so do you see
particular usefulness of measuring the
quantitative results using camera
methods si yes I prefer the quantitative
se however so right now this
chemiluminescence method from two
different companies that we we have used
they all for qualitative only dot for
quantitation I think I should but in
technically it should be not be
difficult to quantify them with
chemiluminescence but I don't know why
they use so far for the computation only
probably maybe that's easier to be
approved by the FDA I'm not sure okay
okay thank you dr. Chen for the answer
to the question and so this we have so
far we have discussed all the five
questions with our foreign speakers so
many I'll just you know express my
appreciation for myself and knock out to
all the speakers our forum chair
professor Wang our foreign speakers dr.
yang dr. Chen and dr. Jung
thank you very much for coming to the
webinar to help us further to deliver
the message and your experience and
useful information to the clinical labs
scientists in the United States who are
going to start testing the coven 19
samples okay thank you all for coming to
the webinar and thank you again to our
students
Thank You doctors for your informative
presentation as a reminder our speakers
will follow up with any questions you
have submitted via email following this
webinar then we'd also like to thank
laberd's for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on-demand through the end of this
year 2020 lag routes will alert you via
email when it's available for Wheatland
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye